Uh,
Tim Kennedy,
who was a guest of mine recently,
a friend of mine said something very profound.
He said,
hard times make tough men.
Easy Times make weak men.
Yeah,
but hard men make easy times.
Eh,
you know,
Nice.
You think about it that way.
Hard,
hard times make tough men.
Tough men make easy times.
Easy Times make weak men.
Yeah.
It's like a
grow cycle riding.
When people are always like,
kids today,
these kids today don't know.
Well it's because they haven't gone through it now you can't.
You can't manufacture that for them.
My Grandmother,
this is a funny story on uh,
on nine 11,
I was a,
in New York,
it was at Newark.
You don't hear that a lot.
By the way.
This is a funny story.
Nine 11,
but I was at Newark.
I was flying out that day and we watched the second plane fly into the,
you saw the second one.
I saw it,
saw it on television at Newark.
You look right across it.
You were looking at you actually literally across our 100%.
I was the first plane it hook was going through your mind when you saw it?
Well,
the first one hit on before we got there,
before I got there and I walked with a pilot down like through the airport and
he said,
yeah,
I think it was a Cessna,
you know,
just kind of crazy.
And I'm,
so I'm down there and I'm,
I was at the,
at the desk and I said I was going to Chicago and I said to the woman working
the thing,
I said,
do you think we're going to fly out today?
Uh,
you know,
do you think we're going to actually get out?
And a guy yells,
here comes another one.
This man,
just like businessmen and we all turn and you could just see it streaking across
right into the small,
the public plane look small,
but you just
insane.
So I sit down,
I just sat,
we just,
and I was sitting with an artist,
I'm a middle aged man who was an artist and a,
and then we heard about the Pentagon as we were sitting there and he opened up
his little art case and it had all these razors in it,
like razor blades and stuff from his artwork.
Like,
you know,
he's a commercial artist and he's like,
this is all going to change.
She said,
you know,
people are just,
they let me on the plane with this and we're just sitting there like just
freaked out,
like calm but freaked out.
And I was calling my wife who was in New York and I woke her up and we were
trying to,
you know,
talk and she was going to the thing.
And uh,
at one point that the artists I was sitting with just looked at me like in my
eyes,
like we were trying to understand what was happening.
He said,
I think we should go home now.
I was like,
yeah,
right.
Of course we should after sitting there for 20 minutes.
So I can't get back into New York.
I can't get back into the city.
Time's gone gone by.
And my man on a cat in a cab going up the parkway in New Jersey and there's just
dust where the towers were.
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
So I can't get in.
So I go to my Nana's house who lives in by giant stadium and uh,
cause she's the closest to the city.
I can't get into the city.
So this,
uh,
this driver takes,
it takes us over and I get to my Nana's house and she's so excited to see me
because her grandsons visiting and she lives alone.
Now.
My father grandfather had passed and I'm sitting in front of the TV and I'm
like,
Nana,
like at first I hugged her and I was like all weepy.
Like I was shaking,
you know,
I didn't know what was happening.
And she's like,
oh,
it's so nice to see you get in here.
It was that visit.
This is so great.
I'm like,
did you see what's happening?
She's like,
ah,
I know.
It's a crazy world.
And,
uh,
I sit in their little tiny living room,
den area and we have the TV on and uh,
she's trying to talk to me and I'm trying to watch the television and she,
this is the World War II mentality.
Uh,
I,
I'm like,
yeah man,
I'm kind of avoiding talking to her.
And she goes,
all right,
well look,
I have a bridge game,
a card game with my lady friends here.
Take half of my sandwich.
She reached her open,
her Tim Tinfoil gave me half of her tuna fish sandwich.
You eat this,
I'm going to go play cards with my friends and we'll have dinner after you'll be
okay.
And she,
and she walks out.
Wow.
But they were tough.
They dealt with so much.
I hadn't dealt with anything.
I'm freaking out,
not even freaking out.
She's like,
it's a crazy world.
And this was,
she wasn't like,
you know,
Alzheimer's.
She was just,
hey,
you know,
it is what,
it has
lost a couple of buildings and a few thousand people.
There's half a sandwich.
I'm going to go play.
I'm going to play bridge.
We've got to keep moving.
Okay.
Tomorrow's another day,
but that's how they live.
Both my grandmothers in that way,
just completely like plow ahead,
plow ahead.
Don't get caught up thinking about everything that's happening because there's
no sense in it.
We've done that before and you get nowhere,
so let's just keep going this way.
Yeah.
Wow.
Having a war that affected people the way World War II did with the entire
nature,
not just the entire nation was involved,
but the whole world was involved in this conflict to stop evil.
Yeah.
It was a different time.
You had an evil doer.
Yeah.
You had a real,
I mean obviously isis is evil.
Obviously North Korea,
there's a lot of evil in the world.
It's not like this evil empire that's invading Europe and dropping bombs on
people.
It's not the same.
It's not no Nazis that believe in eugenics and wanted to create an area in race
that was putting,
handling my hams and not stopping the spreading telling people were coming
and they were the most sophisticated in terms of engineering and like,
I mean they,
they to this day,
I mean,
where do you get all the fucking an engineer's in terms of uh,
like automobiles,
top end,
like Audi,
BMW,
there's those people were making shit for Nazis back then.
Yeah.
They were co opted by the regime.
Did you ever see like one of Hitler's cars?
There's a Audi from like 1930.
[inaudible] it was made for Hitler.
Yeah.
It's like they were designing engines,
planes and they were super sophisticated assistants.
Super advanced now and you'll have this real,
you had this real,
yeah.
Evil Focus.
Like it was like,
okay,
the world has got to come and go get this one guy.
I don't know.
I mean I wasn't there,
but it seems more black and white and the way the world is not sure.
I mean,
there was a thing called operation paperclip that happened,
um,
where after the war we scooped up all these Nazi scientists secretly,
and some of them were like legit,
like Wernher von Braun,
the guy who was in charge of NASA.
He was a Nazi rally.
100%.
The Simon Wiesenthal Center said that if he was alive today,
they would prosecute him for crimes against humanity.
And he was the head of NASA.
He was the head of NASA.
Geez.
Yeah.
They took monsters.
Wow.
And they brought those monsters over here and those monsters helped us make up
the Apollo rockets cheese.
And then some of the monsters went to the Soviet Union.
They took some of those monsters can hills.
Where I mean in,
there's no reason to whitewash that either.
Those were real monsters.
They hung the five slow as Jews every day in front of the,
of the rocket factory in Berlin where Wernher von Braun was making rockets for
the Nazis.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They had these Jews that were slaves that worked as well.
I mean there's people that were alive today that have those tattoos in their
arms that talked about meeting him there and shaking hands and they,
they would hang the slowest workers.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
In the front of the factory and the skinny now keeps going to work.
It doesn't split.
It doesn't leave a country.
W what did you do?
And then,
um,
in Nazi Germany,
how the fuck did you get out?
You were a slave?
No,
not the choose talking about bearing the guys who are on Braun because we were
working for the,
uh,
for the company.
Like to see the people being hung and still hang in there.
They were Nazis.
I mean he was a Nazi.
We're all in.
Yeah.
I mean,
whether or not he agreed with the ideology wholeheartedly.
I didn't have a conversation with him.
I Dunno if he was doing for pragmatic purposes cause was frightened or whatever.
Yeah.
But get a disguise.
Get out of there.
I don't think they could,
you know,
one of those glasses with the mustaches does that work?
Or you go to the airport,
you get on a flight.
Come to
you,
take it off.
They're like,
oh,
it's like with NASA guy.
Well,
this is like a socket.
There was a slow slide,
I'm sure into that.
I mean,
the,
the slot,
what wasn't that slow,
but from world war one or World War II was it escalated?
Yeah.
I think it just got to this point where they're like,
oh my God.
Like what are we doing?
When they started having concentration camps and killing all these Jews,
God terrifying.
And those,
so we took a lot of those guys brought him over here.
They worked for,
worked for the U S government.